[Music]
so
[Music]
you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up
well the government changed their minds
and impose a windfall tax on oil and gas
companies
what i want to see is significant
investment back into the uk if that
doesn't happen
then as i said no option is off the
table
[Music]
wildfires hit the mansions of southern
california with climate change getting
the blame
and the battle to protect the mangroves
in puerto rico
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world hear from
the people being hit hardest by those
changes and reports on the race for
solutions
and tonight we start with what's
beginning to look like a potential
u-turn from the government with the
government under enormous pressure to
deal with the rising cost of living both
the prime minister and the chancellor
have today refused to rule out a
windfall tax on oil and gas company
profits here's rishi sunak this morning
so i'm not naturally attracted to the
idea of windfall taxes in general i find
that people fall into two camps often on
windfall tax is there a group of people
who think you could never have a
windfall tax and then there's another
group of people who think they're a very
easy answer to every problem now i'm not
in either of those camps i'm pragmatic
about it what i do know is that these
companies are making very significant
profits right now because of the unique
prices that we're seeing what i want to
see is significant investment back into
the uk into into the economy for jobs
and energy security and i want to see
that soon if that doesn't happen then as
i've said no option is off the table
well let's take a look at how much money
the uk oil and gas companies have made
will shell have made seven
billion pounds in the first three months
of this year while bp reported a deca
decade high of 5 billion pounds now both
have pledged to invest in green energy
technology in the uk shell plans to
invest between 20 and 25 billion pounds
in the uk energy system over the next
decade and more than 75 percent of that
in low carbon energy with the rest going
into uk gas and oil supplies including
in the north sea and bp has said it will
invest 18 billion pounds in britain in
the great majority in offshore wind
solar hydrogen carbon capture and
storage and of course electric vehicle
charging well sky's business
correspondent helen ann smith was
speaking to the chancellor this morning
in stoke-on-trent what we heard from the
chancellor today on whimple taxes was
really some of the softer language we've
heard from him on the record on the
subject you might be wondering why i'm
surrounded by plates and what this has
got to do with windfall taxes i'm at
royal stafford it's a pottery and
ceramics factory in stoke on trent it
crucially is a very high energy
intensive business uses a huge amount of
energy this company alone is
renegotiating its energy contract at the
moment and their energy bills could
potentially go up as much as 400 or even
600 so
how do we answer some of these questions
of huge energy prices for businesses and
for individuals as well well one of the
options on the table that labor in
particular have been proposing is the
windfall tax to uh tax the very specific
excessive profits that have been made
recently for from bp and shell
and other such companies have made a lot
of money out of these high energy prices
the chancellor and the prime minister
certainly up until now have been
resisting it and the reason they say is
they don't want to deter
investment into the uk particularly
green investment
if they were to put these taxes on uh
however the language
from uh some of the oil and gas
companies has softened a little on that
bernard looney uh last week indicated
that he would uh certainly retain some
of the commitments he's already made
but perhaps was a little softer in his
language on whether he would withdraw
other investment commitments as well so
perhaps in that context uh the
chancellor feels that the it will be
easier for him uh to act if you like the
other reason perhaps is that pressure on
him really really growing the cost of
living crisis getting
excessively worse forecasts from the
bank of england last week that the
economy will contract that there could
be a recession that inflation is going
to exceed 10
uh really a sense that the prime
minister wants to do more as well it may
get to a stage where the chancellor
cannot resist big action like this
anymore and a windfall tax certainly an
option on the table and one he's
speaking softer about now
now for some of the day's other climate
news now because new research has found
extreme weather could help replenish
shorelines eroded by rising sea levels
caused by climate change now academics
from australia the u.s the uk also found
huge large waves can drag sand from
beaches and it dumps it along the
surrounding coastline and global warming
is also expected to increase
wave heights during extreme weather
events along with almost three fifths of
the world's coastline by the end
century but new findings could
potentially change long-term predictions
about the future of our coastlines
a record-breaking number of companies
across 70 countries have set emission
reduction targets according to a climate
think tank the report
from the science-based targets
initiative says more than 2 000 firms
have joined the initiative but the
report says there's still work to be
done highlighting that companies in asia
africa and latin america are lagging
behind europe the u.s and japan
octopus energy group has announced a new
partnership with aims to deliver wind
and solar energy from morocco to the uk
by 2027 x-links plans to lay the world's
largest sub-sea cables to connect a huge
renewable energy farm in the moroccan
desert with devon now the project is
expected to improve uk energy security
and deliver reliable clean power for an
average of 20 hours a day that's enough
energy to power about 7 million heat
pumps all year round
now wildfires continue to wreak havoc in
the united states as the country's
largest in new mexico forced evacuations
from a mountain resort and flames also
whipped through a coastal area in
southern california destroying several
homes now the area was extremely dry and
flammable but hadn't burnt for years but
the local police chief put the blame
squarely on climate change
the winds we experienced today are not
unusual these were not santa ana winds
these are uh our coastal winds that we
experience generally every day
the big difference is and we're seeing
it again
you know with with the climate change
the fuels
beds in this county throughout southern
california throughout the west are so
dry
that you know fire like this is going to
be more commonplace
nbc's steve patterson reports now from
laguna niguel in southern california
as the sun is coming up now here in
orange county this appears to be
what amounts to a hot spot operation
firefighters going from home to home in
this multi-million dollar neighborhood
to make sure that all the smoldering and
the hot spots are contained the fire
though was absolutely devastating you
can see the home behind me this is one
of several in this neighborhood a
neighborhood of multi-million dollar
ruins i'm seeing maybe every fifth home
on this block in my eyesight has been
completely reduced to rubble it is
extreme the nature and the intensity and
the speed of this fire firefighters say
as of about five o'clock last night this
fire was maybe three acres maybe it was
five acres then firefighters watched it
jump five acres by five acres until it
was about 40 acres and then leaping to
hundreds of acres the fire racing up
bone dry heavy vegetation on us on the
side of a canyon here the fire cresting
over that canyon leaping with embers
onto rooftops in this neighborhood and
then those embers leap from roof to roof
to roof as wind gust of about 30 miles
per hour driven by these coastal ocean
winds leap from house to house really
destroying at least 20 homes uh in this
neighborhood alone firefighters working
on containment now but it is clear as it
is only may extremely early for this
time of year here in california that
climate change is driving a lot of this
especially how dry the vegetation is
exacerbating that mega drought that this
state has been in for so long the state
in a water crisis only further making
fire conditions worse and when you have
a situation like that with the
superheated temperatures that will come
later in the summer california residents
are already bracing for what could come
and what has already happened we've seen
here very unusual very bizarre for a
fire this small to move this fast this
early in the season firefighters working
on cleanup working to get people back to
see their homes but for now it's a it's
an operation to try to keep people away
from this area as they work on the rest
of the hot spots
now mangroves are a powerful natural
solution to climate change the trees
which grow along coastal wetlands are
not only a huge carbon store
counteracting emissions they also
protect vulnerable communities from
storm surges but as we'll hear some
residents of puerto rico are battling to
save some mangroves which are at risk
from urban development which is against
the law take a look
a
[Music]
[Music]
a
[Music]
and a bit of slightly unexpected news
despite global warming and some ice ice
shelves in eastern antarctic have grown
over the last 20 years now this is
research published in the journal nature
geoscience it's suggesting that the
growth was produced by changes in wind
direction which pushed sea ice up
against the shelves now the ice shelves
were found to have grown between 2003
and 2019 but since then an increasing
number of icebergs have broken away from
the eastern antarctic peninsula
well do stay with us coming up
i'll be joined by dr shihu who works
with oxford's environmental change
institute and richard black an honorary
fellow with the grantham institution
will be asking how oil and gas companies
can be persuaded
to reduce emissions see you soon
[Music]
so jim jim travels quite frequently uh
on sort of geology and archaeology
interest trips with other hobbyists
um and
travel to iraq with an organized tour
group around a variety of historical
sites and mosques and things as well as
sort of desert desert ruins and things
in iraq um and on visiting a site called
eredu
found some pieces of broken stone and
shards of broken pottery on the ground
kind of asked whether it would be all
right if he takes a few home to stick on
the bookshelf at home as souvenirs of
the trip
um he was told that that would be fine
because they have no historical or
economic value that was confirmed by
the sort of experienced tour group that
he was with and also by a iraqi ministry
tourism official and uh a former police
officer who was with them as security
and then upon arriving at the airport
jim was arrested and charged with
attempting to smuggle historical
artifacts out of the country and that
was eight weeks ago he's still in
detention at the airport so we've
received no kind of ministerial
engagement of any kind um we've we've
never spoken directly with any anyone
with sort of political decision making
capability but the the fcdo are very
keen to to sort of point out and we
acknowledge they are providing consular
support it's worth calling out what that
is that's that is uh weekly or you know
every other week visit to jim to make
sure that he's been fed and watered that
is providing us with the phone number of
an english-speaking lawyer in iraq
um and
that's about it so so you know i mean
under the assumption that the foreign
office looks after british citizens who
run afoul of
injustice abroad um you know we feel
like this could certainly be doing more
and just you know we are just urging the
minister to just meet with us to discuss
ways in which you know they they are
helping or or all ways in which they can
help
we've not spoken verbally since since
before he was arrested so let's say just
just coming up on eight weeks now um but
he gets online uh our time about one am
for for between five and ten minutes
there's a flurry of messages and he sort
of picks up what we've been sending him
throughout the day and replies a few
times and then disappears again but
as i said the consular staff on the
ground have been to visit him and they
assure us that he is being part of food
and water and sort of you know his basic
needs are being looked after but you
know it's eight weeks in a temporary
holding cell in an airport in baghdad
can't be uh can't be comfortable of
course
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news so it's time
now to discuss some of those climate
issues of the day with dr shihu and
environmental consultant uh richard
black thank you both for joining us this
evening so i guess the first big topic
then despite promises and pledges made
at the un climate conference in glasgow
oil and gas companies are well they're
ruling the roost vast profits as we've
heard and according to reporting in the
guardian this week huge ongoing
investments in projects that could see
carbon emissions
spiral out of control well richard to
you first are you hopeful then that cop
27 when it comes around will help drive
that conversation to deter oil and gas
companies from developing
i think it may play a role but the
reality is there are a number of
countries that are not you know
themselves convinced of the need to cut
back on oil and gas production right now
and unsurprisingly those come those
countries include the ones that produce
the most oil and gas and
i don't think that any international
agreements really are going to make them
do that i think the real uh secret the
real way that the the output of
oil and gas companies is going to be
undermined the main way anyway is
basically by them being undercut on
price
and if you look at what's happening in
the energy industry
there is virtually no country on earth
now where it's cheaper to build and
operate a new gas fire power station
than it is to build and operate a new
solar farm or a new wind farm
and in many cases it's actually cheaper
to build a new solar farm and operate it
than it is to carry on with an existing
power station that you have
meanwhile in the electric car
field which is the main you know way to
undercut oil demand sales are going
bananas we're talking about you know
each year the number of sales going up
by maybe 40 percent
compounded so they just keep going up
and in the end this is just i think
going to eat the market of oil and gas
companies and cc i guess there's a big
drive um like richard said to invest in
green energy isn't there
and that's been pushed on i suppose by
the war in ukraine um is there still
room though for those big countries the
middle east the u.s australia canada to
understand where green energy should be
yes i think so um although i think what
really matters is the content of the
talks in these sort of um climate talks
and diplomacies right so the problem is
there is a fundamental mismatch between
the promises that are being made by the
countries um and the market incentives
so if we're going back to you know oil
and gas companies at any company they
are driven by making money so what we
should be thinking about is whether
these governments who are engaging in
climate talks and diplomacy have the
economic tools to change the behavior of
these companies because ultimately
they're here to make a profit and
whatever tools we come up with have to
alter that profit equation somehow to be
effective um in terms of reducing
emissions so do you think cc a carbon
tax would be important for businesses to
sort of really get on board with green
initiatives
yeah so carbon taxes um you know carbon
trading schemes have been in place um
and there have been some successes what
we need to do is to learn as fast as
possible from um you know designing
these lessons and if they don't work we
really need to come up with some better
tools but ultimately the economic the
market incentives have to be there for
these companies to change their behavior
uh richard i'd like your insight really
into how these big oil and gas companies
they really view
you know climate summits cop26 how do
they view them are they running scared
or is it something they want to engage
in
i think just just before i i i i have a
go at that i think
i agree well i agree with what sisi said
um the reality is that there are many of
the really big uh gas and oil companies
that basically are governments if you
look at saudi arabia if you look at
qatar as we're seeing russia china you
know this is not a not a question where
these are external companies to be
regulated by a government they kind of
are the government so that sheds a
different light on things i think some
of the companies um look at the
summits as something where they can
basically try to sell their version of
going green and their version of going
to net zero and that's actually shared
by some governments as well if you look
at the plans put forward by saudi arabia
australia russia for example for getting
to net zero by mid century they all
posit um
keeping fossil fuel extraction at
current levels or even increasing it so
basically the summit can be a way to try
and sell the carbon capture and storage
blue hydrogen type root
where basically you carry on producing
fossil fuels and magically you you get
to net zero
okay that leads us really nicely really
on to our next big topic which is
targets um because we know uh that a
record number of big polluting companies
are committing to cutting uh co2
emissions and this is all from a un
backed report and then separately to
that they've cast out on whether oil
companies can kind of deliver on those
targets too so richard i'll start with
you how accountable are these top
companies when it comes to you know big
grand gestures and big targets that they
do put out there
yes most of the companies that are
looked at here are the big publicly are
publicly traded companies and there are
all kinds of sectors you know whether it
be retail um manufacturing all kinds of
things ultimately they're accountable to
their to their to their shareholders and
of course we've seen in recent years a
number of times shelled as you know
passing resolutions that basically make
the directors uh pay more attention to
this stuff a lot of the time they'll be
beholden to their customers
because you know particularly in europe
uh there is a tradition of companies
decide sorry customers deciding who they
will buy from based on the behavior of
that particular company and then the
other thing that's coming up on the
rails is really regulation and in many
countries uh and jurisdictions um
companies are increasingly have to
having to disclose what their climate
risk is for example so all these things
are playing a role but it's not there's
no sort of monolithic solution here it's
going to be incremental it's going to be
messy and not all companies and all
places are going to have to toe the line
at the same time
cece we do know that more than half of
these companies setting targets are in
the g7 rich nations don't we but
india china brazil they're also in the
mix it's quite encouraging that isn't it
yes i think it's it's really um
essential that companies are actually um
now making pledges um because carbon
production is um you know at the company
level ultimately um although i i agree
with richard
everything that he said i think i'm
gonna throw in a bit of a
pessimistic thing in terms of a
challenge here i think um companies um
don't necessarily know how to quantify
emissions and then i think that's one of
the key problems right now right even if
you pledge um if you can't quantify and
you don't know where your missions are
coming from then how are you supposed to
come up with the best practices how
you're supposed to prioritize how are
you supposed to evaluate most
importantly of your progress um oil and
gas companies in particular uh you know
struggle with leaks um so there's a lot
of challenges around these you know
pipelines running thousands of miles and
nobody knows how much gas greenhouse
gases is you know leaked um so yeah do
companies have the capacity to measure
emissions properly that's one of the key
challenges um
but yeah there is progress to be made um
it is about trust it's about
accountability but one thing that is
clear richard mark carney very briefly
is warning governments they can't derail
the climate process um
with the war in ukraine do you agree
yes i do but you have to say that for
many governments that otherwise i think
would be saying strong things about the
climate talks at the moment they're not
because their attention is focused on
ukraine and it's not just the conflicts
as well we've seen the energy
prices around the world affected we're
going to see food prices around the
world affected so these are all visceral
things in europe we're actually looking
i think at accelerating decarbonization
because people are now realizing
politicians are now realizing that in
the words of the german finance minister
christian lindner renewable energy is
freedom energy and on that note we'll
leave it thank you cece and richard a
pleasure talking to you today well do
stay with us coming up at nine uh sky
political editor beth rigby will be
speaking to vladimir chishoff the
russian ambassador to the european union
that's coming up on beth rigby
interviews well that's a big thank you
for us for watching we'll see you next
time bye
[Music]
you